JASON CLARK: Good afternoon.
This session is how to
industrialize your data
platform with Google Cloud
Platform and open source
technology.
I'm Jason Clark.
I've been with Monsanto/Bayer
for a little over nine years
now.
So to start with,
who here has seen
it an ear of corn up
close and personal?
If you have, you've
probably noticed
that on that
individual ear of corn
there are a lot of
individual kernels, right?
On an ear of corn, you can have
anywhere between 100 and 1,200
kernels on that single ear.
Each of those kernels has a lot
of information packed inside.
A lot of information
that's very useful to us
within Bayer Crop Science
and making decisions
on how we drive our
product pipeline.
And what I want to
talk to you today
is essentially asking
the question like,
what if we could take all
that data that's packed
inside each of those kernels--
each of those kernels that
are on those ears that
are in these fields
where there's
thousands of corn plants.
What if we could take data
about each of those kernels
and engineer an information
pipeline that can help us mass
produce knowledge about
our product pipeline
and ultimately make more
informed decisions that help
drive useful products to market
that can aid in producing
more bountiful harvests?
What I want to
convince you of is
that we have, as an
engineering team,
produced an information
pipeline that
leverages historic observations,
crop data that we have
to further characterize
our products
and ultimately improve
decision making,
but at a fraction of the
costs that we would incur
to have done it previously.
So let's take a step back here.
I'm with Barry G. I'm actually
more a part of Bayer Crop
Science.
And when we look at our
product pipeline for Bayer Crop
Science, it really comes down
to three high level steps.
Number one, we're going
to try to identify
market needs, right?
What treatments can
we pair with seeds
and genetic characteristics that
we know about our corn plants?
As an example, how can we
pair these things together
and produce a product
that ultimately improves
yield for our farmer customers?
Once we've identified what
those market needs are,
we'll start to actually
develop those product concepts.
Step two.
When we're developing those,
what we're ultimately doing
is over the course of years,
taking each one of those seeds,
planting them, pollinating them,
harvesting them, and starting
that whole cycle over.
Shipping seed around the globe
and perform that cycle year
over year.
And while we're planting
and harvesting these things,
in between there, we're
measuring a lot of data
and recording a lot of
data about those seeds.
Fundamentally,
there are two data
sets that our team cares about
that contribute to driving
that product pipeline.
Genetic data,
which would include
genomics, and phenotypic data.
So genetic data
being, what do we
know about the genetic makeup,
the genome of these seeds
that we're moving through
a product pipeline?
And phenotypic data being,
what can we actually observe?
Is this year of corn
yellow, or is it white?
Right?
That's a very simple
characteristic.
But you can imagine much
more complex characteristics
that we're measuring as well.
And then ultimately,
once we've identified
that product concept, we've
developed this product concept,
we're sure it's the right
fit for our customers,
we'll commercialize it.
At each of these
steps along the way,
there are different
elements of our data stack
that are important.
And what I want to
do today is tell you
who we are as an
engineering team,
and then tell you how we've
applied some principles
to industrialize our platform
and allow for large scale
across our consumers and within
our platform to ultimately
produce knowledge.
So who are we?
How do I fit into this picture?
I work for a really
strong engineering
team called Product360
within our data landscape.
What we do is we engineer a
versatile enterprise wide data
asset platform that's really
core to other business layers.
What does that mean?
Well, fundamentally, what we
do is we provide access to core
product data sets in various
ways, various modes of access
across various personas.
So everything from
other software products
that are being built
within the company
to data scientists that
are trying to identify what
those next product
concepts could be,
all the way up to our domain
experts, the people working
in the labs.
The people that are
really doing the hands on
work to measure and
observe characteristics
about these seeds that are
moving through our pipeline.
Now what that means is that
with that variety of consumers
and spanning that long
of a pipeline-- again,
the course of years--
we really build up
some demand in terms
of usage of the
platform that we built.
To kind of give you a
sense for that usage--
API requests.
So again, the fundamental
mode of access for the data
sets that our team
delivers is through APIs.
And we'll get into kind of
the different modes of access
for those APIs in
just a few moments.
But what you can see here
is on average, monthly,
over the course
of the last year,
we've had 323
million API requests.
So we're not talking
internet scale.
But we're talking
pretty sizable usage
when you consider that
all these consumers are
within our company.
Now, another thing that you
can see here is peak usage.
And what you can see is that
agriculture is fundamentally
a seasonal business, right?
We'll see spikes in
usage at various times
throughout the year.
We've seen one month where
we have had 1.16 billion API
requests across our platform.
So who are those coming from?
Well, we measure that as well.
And we'll talk a little
bit later on about how
we measure this data.
Active applications.
So application being considered.
A software product that's
using our platform in some way.
An analytical model that's
Also, inclusive of
individual data scientists
that may be using our
platform in some way.
We've seen an average of 85
active applications per month,
spiking up to, again, 116
with those seasonal workloads.
Now our platform
is not stagnant.
It's not stale.
It's changing every day.
We release on average
23 times a month
to production, with a
peak in there of releasing
more than one time of day.
Now, we're not releasing
hundreds of times a day.
We don't have that need.
But what it does show is that
our platform is still evolving.
And some of the principles
that I'm going to talk to you
about give us that
wiggle room to continue
to evolve the platform as we
continue to expand the usage
and provide value
for our consumers.
Produce new knowledge
for the organization.
To kind of give you a sense of
the breadth of the platform,
we're looking at a little
over 40 resource collections.
All those data sets,
those resources
are all different
shapes and sizes.
Some may be graphed
structured data.
Some may be traditional
relational data.
They're all different,
but they all
fit into the puzzle in some way.
And we don't just
distribute our databases.
We distribute our
engineering team as well.
We've got a team of 30-plus
data engineers split into five
to seven person teams focused
on different vertical areas
within Product360.
So with demand like
that, how do we
go about building
a platform that we
can scale, that we can use,
that our consumers can use,
and our consumers can scale?
To do that, we've had to
develop some basic principles.
And if we think
about this like we're
designing a factory
of knowledge here
and we're trying to layout
our factory floor, what
are some of the principles
in designing that factory
floor that we've
tried to follow?
Well, step number one is we want
to minimize retooling, right?
We don't want to have to
reconfigure that factory floor
and incur downtime in that
production of knowledge
if we don't have to.
We want to minimize that.
Number two is we
want standardization.
And we want each component
on that factory floor,
we want its job and its purpose
in life to be obvious, right?
We want somebody to be able to
look at that layout and say,
I know why this piece is here.
But we also want
that indirection
as an engineering team
to be able to swap
a new component in that
it does that job at least
a little bit better
if necessary, right?
So we want that
ability to refactor,
but we don't want to cause our
consumers to have to retool.
The next thing is, if our
factory floor stops working,
we're no good for our consumers.
We're not producing knowledge.
We need a really clear view
of the health of our factory
floor, right?
We need key
performance indicators
that can tell us how that
factory floor is operating
and where the bottlenecks
are at, right?
Where are we
introducing bottlenecks
into this process of
producing knowledge?
So I want to walk you through,
in the next few slides,
how we apply some
of these principles
and how we design for them.
And then, what I want
to do is come back
and make it more real.
So we'll talk kind
of in an abstract way
about those principles
over the next few slides.
And then we'll bring
it back, and we'll
talk through a real
use case and show you
how we've applied
those principles
in a real information pipeline.
So let's start with
standardization, right?
We want those components to
easily be swapped in and out,
but we want their
purpose to be obvious.
That comes back, to me, to
readability and flexibility.
Those two things.
So let's start with readability.
If we think about readability
from a code perspective,
what does that mean?
It means, fundamentally,
my code base
is more maintainable
because someone else
can come in and understand
what that software is intending
to do.
We want our data model
to operate the same way.
We want our consumers to
be able to come in, look
at one resource, get
familiar and comfortable
with that resource.
And then, when they go
to use another resource,
not have to worry
about reconfiguring
their mental model.
We want it to look similar.
We want our resources
to look similar such
that they can jump
across those resources
with a minimal
amount of friction
and really combine data together
to produce new information
for the company.
Standardization is
how we get there.
And the way we've
standardized is
by adopting Google's resource
oriented design guidelines.
If you've ever used
the Google Cloud APIs,
this will feel familiar to you.
This is a lot of the principles
that are applied in the Google
Cloud APIs.
And you'll see some
things show up here
in a few moments directly out
of those design guidelines.
One thing that really
cemented for me
kind of putting
importance in API design
was Martin Nally's
talk last year
at Cloud Next called
Designing Quality APIs.
It's a really good
watch if you're
interested in API design,
and why it's important,
and how to go about it.
It's a really good watch and
a really good place to start.
Now, we talked
about readability.
Standardization is helping
give us that readability.
And it's helping
give us that ability
to swap in new components
as an engineering team.
But what about flexibility?
If we're so rigid that we have
to change our APIs every time
a new attribute's introduced
into a business workflow
that maybe it's something
hyperspecific to that workflow,
that's going to be
retooling for us-- that's
going to be potentially
retooling for our consumers
by way of a breaking
change to or APIs,
or a new version of an API that
they have to rapidly adopt,
right?
It's going to cause churn.
It's going to potentially
cause downtime and loss
of productivity.
So what we've done is
we've adopted a concept
from the resource oriented
design guidelines.
With these guidelines, we
try to not be dogmatic.
We try to be pragmatic.
So we'll start with the resource
oriented design guidelines, use
that as our base.
And then, if there's something
that maybe makes more sense
because we have more context
about our development
workflow or our customer's
workflows, we'll adapt it.
And we'll make it fit that.
But we use the resource oriented
design guidelines as our base.
Resource annotations
are an example of that.
There's a concept in resource
oriented design called labels.
And if you've used
the Google Cloud APIs,
again, you've seen this concept.
Or really, any cloud API, you've
seen this concept in some way.
It's essentially bring
your own context, right?
I don't have to tell
Google Cloud, hey,
can you add this attribute
to the Compute Engine API
so that I can capture it?
I can add that.
And it's specific to me.
And it's relevant to me.
It's understandable to me.
We've adopted that same
principle with our API design.
We've got a lot of workflows
internally that spin up
and spin down quickly, right?
We want to be that base.
We don't want to have
to change our APIs
and introduced downtime
with every change
to the business workflow.
So this enables that
bring your own context.
An example here is that this
is really just key value pair
data, right?
So we've got some
base schema that
is giving you a definition of
the core enterprise attributes
for that particular resource.
And then, you've got
annotations that you
can apply on top
of that resource
to bring your own context.
An example would be if I want
to label a particular seed
as being part of a
drought initiative,
I could add that annotation
by way of a key value pair.
And in some cases,
we do have controlled
vocabulary implemented over
some of those annotations.
But mostly, it's free form.
It's meant to be a piece of
flexibility for our consumers.
Another way that we
enable flexibility
is through this concept
of resource sets.
So we've got
resource collections
that we expose as APIs.
And then, I think
what we've seen
a lot of is that people
like their things,
and they like their
groups of things.
They want to bring context by
way of taxonomically organizing
that data in some way that's
meaningful and relevant
to them.
Resource sets give us that.
It's another resource.
It's structured as a
resource standard API,
but it gives you the ability
to group a particular resource
by way of filter values, right?
So let's say I wanted to keep
a list of all the products
that are moving through
the pipeline for 2019.
If I have a product resource
and a product sets resource,
I can do that.
I can provide filter parameters
and I can either manually
update that thing,
or we're moving more
towards this concept of dynamic
sets, which is basically filter
parameters with context, right?
So give it a name.
Name that thing.
And then, it can be reused
across the organization.
It's a way to
deduplicate that data,
but also give our consumers some
control and some flexibility
in the management of that data.
The other side here
is that we don't
want to impose trade-offs
on our consumers
where we don't have to.
We want to push the ability
to make trade-offs back
into their control.
There are a couple of
ways that we do that.
So I've talked in generality
about resource APIs, right?
Resource just being a
particular data set.
We provide multiple
modes of access
to each of those data sets.
One is gRPC.
So we've wholesale adopted
gRPC across our platform
as a mode of access
for each data set.
We've also enabled REST.
We see definitely more
usage on the REST side
from less technical consumers.
People like data scientists.
People that are just that aren't
programmers but are trying
to get their job done and need
to interact with these APIs
to access these data sets.
REST is going to work with
more out of the box tooling
and just be an
easier experience,
but gRPC is going to give
you that performance.
We've done some head-to-head
benchmarks of REST versus gRPC
and there's definitely
noticeable performance gain
there with gRPC.
But as a consumer,
as a data scientist,
I don't want to have a
high barrier to entry
for accessing these things.
So we provide both of
these modes of access.
The kicker here is that if
I want to string together
multiple resources to really
make something meaningful,
that can be more
difficult, right?
I have to be somewhat
of a programmer
to be able to do that.
To call these APIs, do some
sort of transformation,
pipe that into another API,
do transformation off of that.
How do we make it
easy for consumers
to join this data together?
That's where GraphQL
comes in for us.
So we've got a
GraphQL server that,
again, can be used by any
of our consumer personas--
bench scientists,
data scientists,
enterprise application--
that can use this GraphQL
server, which in turn calls
our gRPC APIs, right?
So we get the performance
of calling gRPC APIs,
but we can do a
prescriptive join
of that data for the consumers.
This gives, again, the consumer
the ability to trade off
who's doing the join, right?
If they have more knowledge
potentially about a better
way to pre-filter data and join
that with another data set,
they can do that.
They can do that by
way of gRPC or REST.
They have that ability.
If they don't want to join
that data together manually,
they don't have to.
They can call our
GraphQL API and we'll
do that join for them.
Both of those are synchronous
modes of access, right?
Request response
for our consumers.
The third pattern
here that we follow
is we've adopted Cloud
Native Computing Foundations
CloudEvents spec to publish
an event stream for each
of our resources.
That event stream
notifies on standard
create, update, delete
operations, right?
It tells and give
our consumers a hook
into our ecosystem to react
asynchronously to goings
on in our ecosystem.
This, again, gives
our consumers a way
to decide what model fits
their particular workflow.
Whether that's an
enterprise application that
wants to react as new enterprise
state elements are created,
or a data scientist that
is really just trying
to get these data
sets combined together
and move on with their lives
so they can focus on their job,
their core responsibilities.
That's heavily focused on
the consumer side, right?
As an engineering
team, we also try
to take that idea
of standardization
and use that as our
indirection to the back end.
And that gives us the
ability to use data structure
as a competitive advantage.
So again, I mentioned
that we've got
40 plus resource collections.
They're all different
shapes and sizes.
We've got data sets like our
pedigree ancestry data set that
tracks seed lineage, right?
If we think about
that corn kernel.
We plant that.
We pollinate it in some way.
We harvest new seed.
And those seeds are linked
together genetically, right?
One came from the other.
And we do that over the
course of years, sometimes
multiple times a year for
that particular line of seed.
That produces a lot of data.
And that data is naturally
structured as a graph.
And with that data set, what
you see on the right hand side
here of the slide is an
image that my colleague, Tim
Williamson, tweeted a
while back that is actually
a representation of our
ancestry data set for corn.
Each of those stars in
this galaxy are corn seeds,
and the links between them
are genetic relationships.
These seeds came from
these seeds, right?
It gives you a sense of
the scale of that data set.
This is just corn.
Now, we work in a lot
more crops than just corn.
If this is interesting
to you, I would highly
encourage that you go out
and watch Tim's presentation
from GraphConnect
a couple years ago.
He goes more in-depth in how
we've modeled data in neo4j
for that pedigree data.
But the point here
is that we can't
specialize from an engineering
perspective, right?
We have that indirection.
None of this is novel.
But that standardization
gives us a good way
to kind of plug and play.
We can start with a relational
database for a data set
like this if we
wanted to, and then
optimize the back end later.
And with minimal friction,
or ideally no friction
for our consumers.
The other side of
our data footprint
is Cloud Spanner has rapidly
become our primary database.
So we're coming from
a legacy environment
with a large Oracle
instance that
was really good at its job for
what we needed at the time.
As we've moved to more
of a microservice model,
something like Cloud Spanner
has actually become very, very
useful for us.
We've made smaller, thinner,
more well-defined resources
so we're not trying to
facilitate seven table joins
to get data back.
Cloud Spanner has been a really
good fit as well because,
again, different data sets of
different shapes and sizes.
Size being the key word in that.
We have a few data sets
that are very, very large.
And those are the data sets
that we'll actually talk through
in our real life example.
To give you a sense of the
scale of our Spanner footprint,
right now we're at
about 17 terabytes
across our two environments.
About 10 terabytes in our
production environment.
And the other seven in our
non-production environment.
And our instance size floats
between 10 and 50 nodes.
Now that can get expensive.
But we'll talk a
little bit later
about how we try to control
that cost without sacrificing
performance with
Spanner specifically.
So we've talked a lot
about getting data out
of our platform.
Let's talk about how we
get data into our platform.
Our most basic pattern for
getting data into our platform
is essentially a data generator
calling a resource API
by way of gRPC arrest, right?
Again, nothing novel, but
there are some things,
some characteristics about
that particular workflow
that are important.
One, it pushes
resource validation
closer to the data generator.
So if the data generator
gives us bad data,
that is synchronous.
We can immediately
reject that data
and give that data
generator context
as to why that data is invalid.
It keeps muck out of our
enterprise systems, right?
And it also prevents us
as an engineering team
from having to get in the muck
if that bad data is generated.
The other characteristic is that
the consistency model follows
that of the resource API.
So again, Cloud
Spanner is essentially
our primary database
at this point.
With a global
consistency model, we
can provide that same
capability to our consumers.
The flip side of that,
the trade-off here,
is that the data generator is
sensitive to the performance
of the resource API.
If our resource
API is slow and we
don't have alarm bells
sounding from our KPIs,
that data generator
is going to slow down,
or they're going to have to
deal with that in some way.
They're going to have
to engineer complexity
into their system
to accommodate that.
So in cases where
either it's not feasible
for us to make something
hyperperformant
or cases where that write
is just high enough latency
that it impacts
the data generator
and slows their work down,
this pattern may not fit.
There's another pattern where--
that pattern works well
with kind of this new world
that we're building where we're
building new workflows out
in the Cloud and
engineering systems
to bring us into
a new landscape.
Another write
pattern that we have,
though, is we do have,
again, large legacy
systems that have collected
data over the course of 20
to 30 years.
That data is still important.
We still use that data to
make a lot of decisions
in our business because we want
to look at that data over time.
The way we get our legacy data
into our systems in most cases
is through a product
that we have internally
called the Enterprise Data Hub.
What the Enterprise Data Hub
is a set of replicated Kafka
clusters that is managed
by a central engineering
team within our company.
That product takes care of
bidirectional replication
between our different
cloud environments, right?
So we have a Kafka
cluster on prem.
We have a Kafka cluster in AWS.
We have a Kafka cluster in GCP.
And Data Hub takes care of
moving that data in and out
of those environments for us.
On the front end
of that, we have
change data capture mechanisms.
Informatica data replicator
in the case of SAP,
and Oracle GoldenGate in the
case of our Oracle environment.
Those are pushing change
capture records out.
Those change capture
records are making their way
to Golang Kafka consumers
that we have running out
in Google Cloud, and pushing--
again, still pushing things
into our resource API.
So we're dogfooding
those resource APIs, even
in this context.
We're not ever making
direct rights around the API
to our databases, which, again,
one hardens our workflows,
right?
If we're dogfooding
it, we're going
to harden that
workflow much quicker
than waiting for our
consumers to find issues.
And, too, it's given us
some of the same benefit.
We can leverage those
flexibility concepts as well
and adapt our
workflows much quicker.
One thing I would
stress here, too,
is that if you're interested
in learning more about how
our data hub
environment is set up,
a former colleague, Bob
Lehman, speaks of that approach
in Kafka Summit last year.
This is really another
really good watch
that goes more in-depth
into our data hub setup.
So that particular
change pattern
is generally lightweight
events, right?
The change capture records
are maybe 10, 15 columns.
Not big.
And a lot of those can be
kind of treated in isolation.
However, we have a
set of workflows,
particularly in
the genomics world
where we've got a lot of data
that comes from a single event.
So we have a single
change capture
record that comes across.
That single change
record can lead
to creation of thousands
of resources, all of which
are fairly heavy weight.
There's some meat to each of
those individual resources.
To accommodate that
workflow, Kafka really
doesn't encourage you to
put super large messages
on a topic in a partition.
So to accommodate that
workflow, we still stream out
that lightweight event.
We transform that
lightweight event
by joining it back
to the legacy system
and exchanging that
lightweight event for n
number of large resources.
We take each of those resources
and we sync them as objects
in Google Cloud Storage.
When we do that, we rely
on bucket notifications
to publish out the
other side, right?
That's our change
capture mechanism
on the other side
of Cloud storage.
So that bucket
notification fires.
We do, in some cases, a little
more manipulation or massaging
to that data.
And then, again, write it
in through the resource API.
So a similar approach,
but we're accommodating
that large transformation that
has to happen in the middle
there.
And we're doing that
with GCS and PubSub.
One of the things that we get
out of this particular workflow
is that with our
Kafka workflows,
we can't arbitrarily scale
our consumption, right?
Scaling of a Kafka consumer
is bound by the number
of partitions that you have.
And repartitioning is generally
not a pleasant exercise.
PubSub gives us the ability
to arbitrarily scale here.
We have a single event that is
infrequent that comes across,
and we exchange that for a
larger amount of information.
And then, we want to
parallelize really
wide to consume that information
into our resource APIs
as rapidly as possible.
PubSub gives us that ability.
We can scale out much, much
wider with a button push.
Essentially with a change in
a Kubernetes deployment size,
a replica count.
So that's one of the
benefits that we get out
of this particular
workflow as well.
We don't always have control
of our legacy system.
And by control, I mean the
ability to go back and exchange
information with it directly.
An example of that
for us is SAP.
So we don't ever touch our SAP
environment by querying it.
But we do have to change data
capture that's generated out
of our SAP system.
To accommodate
that, we've actually
paired Kafka in those
change capture records
with Spanner and data flow.
So this kind of more of
the traditional replicate
the data as is we replicate
as is into the Spanner.
So you'll see tables
that look like SAP tables
in Cloud Spanner.
And then, we use Cloud Dataflow
to kind of give us this concept
of a materialized view, right?
We've got Cloud Dataflow
running periodically
as a scheduled job, taking
data out of Cloud Spanner,
making it into the format
that we want to make it into
to make it a more descriptive
resource for our consumers,
storing that data
back in Cloud Spanner,
and then our resource
APIs built on top of that.
So it's essentially
a cache, right?
One of the things
that we get out
of using Cloud
Dataflow here-- we're
heavily using Cloud
Dataflow Java.
But one of things we get out
of that is testable business
logic, right?
We can test those
data transformations
that we're doing.
Whereas, if we're traditionally
building 1,000 line SQL
statement to build
a materialized view,
you get testing that is
really hard, and error prone,
and all these other
things that make
it really difficult
to ensure we're not
introducing breaking changes.
With Dataflow and with
Java, obviously we
can unit test in a
similar way that we would
any of our other software.
Another aspect of data
flow that becomes important
here is that we can scale that.
As our data set size scales, we
can increase our worker count.
Again, it's a button push.
So that gives us the ability
to ingest a lot more data
if need be without a lot
of operational overhead
or having to retool
our environment.
The trade-off here
with this workflow
is that this is
not near real time.
These other workflows that we've
looked at are near real time.
Moments after that data is
written to the legacy system,
it'll be available
in our resource APIs
for consumption
by our consumers.
This is not.
This is scheduled.
So this is every few hours,
we run these transformations.
We can squeeze that down and
make it shorter frequency.
We haven't had the
need to do that.
But it does suffer from
this particular aspect.
What you see on the right
is an example of one
of our simple Dataflow jobs.
So when I talk
about testability,
this is kind of showing
this is a simple job.
Testing these things
as it is important.
So we talked a little
bit earlier about
how it's important for us
to have key performance
indicators.
A view of our
factory floor, right?
We don't want to ever stop
that production of knowledge.
We want that to
be available 24/7.
So now, I want to
talk a little bit
about some of the reliability
engineering aspects
that we've introduced
into our stack.
The most basic, but also
one of the most useful,
has been instrumenting our APIs
to capture access log data, API
request data.
This captures essentially
the who, the what, the when,
and the how long for
each of the API requests
that coming into our platform.
This gives us a sense of how
those requests or those APIs
are operating for
our consumers, right?
If it's something slow,
we surface this data
through BigQuery
written through PubSub.
So each API hands off
the request to PubSub.
We've got a process that
syncs that into BigQuery.
And then, we surface it
for our engineering teams
using Data Studio.
So kind of gives you that
end to end experience,
and gives our engineering team
a view of that factory floor,
but a of their specific
segment of that factory floor.
Another aspect.
You've seen how many of the
Ingress patterns rely on Kafka.
What we've done is
create, essentially,
a monitor for Kafka.
That's not novel, right?
But what we did in this
case is use Kubernetes CRDs,
custom resource definitions,
to allow our engineering team
to define their monitoring
requirements for their Kafka
consumers at deployment time.
So instead of having to
deploy my Kafka consumer
and then go somewhere
else to say here's
how I should be
alerted for this thing,
you can push that information
close to the deployment.
This is a place where,
to me, Kubernetes really,
really shines.
This extensibility allows us
to describe our deployment
workflow in the
terms that we use,
and make it discoverable
for our engineers
all through the surface that
they're interacting with
to do their application
development daily.
That alerts the slack.
Push the messages close to
where the engineers are.
But it's a set of really
simple go processes
that are watching for that
custom resource definition
to change.
And last but not least, we've
talked a lot about Spanner.
And I mentioned that if
we're running a large Spanner
instance, that
can get expensive.
We also don't want to run
a small Spanner instance
and have that seasonal
workload spike on us
all of a sudden and
our API performance
goes down the drain, right?
We want stability, but we
also want cost control.
So we've written a simple
autoscaler component
for Cloud Spanner that
runs in Kubernetes, uses
the Stackdriver API to watch for
CPU utilization numbers, right?
It watches that time series
and scales Cloud Spanner
up and down using the
Spanner API as needed.
We've seen this drastically
reduce our Spanner bill
because we were
overallocating before
to guard against
poor performance
if we saturated the instance.
But we've seen now
that CPU utilization
with this autoscaler component
hover between 30% and 50% usage
utilization.
So we want to be using as much
of that capacity as we can.
We can't put those
CPU cycles in the bank
and save them for later.
We're getting what we pay
for at that point in time.
This has been a big addition
in terms of operations.
Again, hands off for
our engineering team.
This autoscaler can take action.
There's a little bit of
risk in that the Stackdriver
API is a minute behind.
So if we see a
real sudden burst,
we may see a few
failed requests.
But overall, over time, it
helps keep our SLOs in check.
So let's make this real.
Let's talk a little bit
about one of the concepts
that we've implemented
on our platform.
This information
pipeline that we've
implemented on our platform over
the course of the last year.
What we're doing is we're
doing a process called
genotype inference.
So think about that corn
seed again, that kernel.
Again, that is each kernel
is dense in information.
What we want is
we want a picture,
a window into the information
inside that kernel.
Generate markers give
us that information
about the genome of that
particular corn seed, right?
So genome being all the
different nucleotide bases
that compose that
kernel genetically.
Genetic marker giving
some measurement
at particular locations
on the genome.
And those locations are picked
very strategically, right?
We're looking for things
that ultimately we
know this marker or
these set of markers
lead to this kernel being
white or yellow, right?
Things that we can observe
that have meaning and value
for our customers.
The way we make
those observations--
we have two different
levels of resolution.
In red, you'll see low
density resolution.
What that is a smaller
number of genetic markers
that we capture spread
across the genome.
In yellow, you'll see
high density observations.
That's a lot more markers.
It's awful lot more
expensive to collect, right?
So these are things where
we're actually sending seeds
to the lab, and we're
running experiments
to get a window into the
genome of these corn seeds.
Now, if we want to capture
low density observations,
it's cheaper.
It's easier.
It can be done more quickly.
But it still costs
a lot of money.
Still costs money, right?
And it's not just the money
of running that experiment.
It's all the shipping
costs, and all
that comes into play to
move seed to actually make
those measurements.
What we've done is we've
leveraged mathematics,
essentially, and programming,
and these technologies
that you've seen me talk about
to infer these genotypes, which
is at a much cheaper cost.
We can basically take the data
that we've measured-- those two
different levels of resolution--
and we can fill in the gaps.
We can up sample the
low density resolution
to a high density
resolution-- high resolution.
And we can fill in
those middle areas
where maybe we didn't
collect any data at all,
but we know genetically, the
seed came from the seed came
from this seed.
And genetics gives us certain
rules that we can put into play
and make estimations
about what the genome
of that particular
seed in the middle,
of which we made no
direct observations,
actually looks like.
We get probabilistic value that
allows, again, our consumers
to make the choice
of how confident they
want to be about that
picture of the genome, right?
Again, allowing the consumer
to make more decisions.
To give you a sense
of how much data
we've generated with this
information pipeline, what
you see, again, in yellow is
the high density observation.
So we collected a lot of
information, a lot of markers
on a smaller number of seeds.
With the low density
observations,
we've collected a
lot fewer marker.
We've observed a
lot fewer markers,
but we've done it on a
larger number of seeds.
The blue is the area
that we've filled in.
I talked to a colleague
this morning just
to make sure that my number
was right on that number--
or on that blue area.
We're talking about
197 billion genotypes
that we were able to generate
and infer from those data sets.
This something that was
previously unachievable,
and we've done it at
a much lower cost.
And we've done it this way.
So let's walk through
this diagram real quick.
This is architecture for this
genotype inference pipeline.
Let's talk about some
of those principles
that we laid out earlier.
So if you go left to right,
starting from the bottom,
we've got a lab
workflow, a lab system
that's pushing data in to our
observed genotypes resource.
That's backed by Cloud Spanner.
All of that data is
in Cloud Spanner.
From there, you've
got a cloud event.
You get that
asynchronous notification
that new data has arrived.
There's a component called
the orchestrator that's
listening for those
events, and then
scheduling these inference jobs.
And it's doing
that on Kubernetes
by way of GKE as
PubSub messages that
get distributed across multiple
regions, multiple Kubernetes
clusters in multiple regions.
Then, those pods, their
sole purpose in life
is to do that
calculation for us.
To do that calculation,
to infer these genotypes,
they'll reach back in
to our resource APIs
to grab those
observed genotypes.
When they complete
their purpose,
they'll write that new data
set out as an inferred genotype
into our inferred
genotype resource.
One interesting thing about
that, one of the Spanner
talks that we were in
earlier this morning,
they talked about using
Spanner for GCS metadata.
Similar approach
here, we actually
use we stored the
metadata for these data
sets in Spanner so that we
can more rapidly search over.
It but the bulk of the
data, the payload for that
is stored in GCS
because it is large.
We're talking 85,000 genotypes
for a single seed, right?
And then, we're talking
millions of seeds
that we're inferring
these genotypes for.
So that that data
set grows rapidly.
A few interesting
characteristics
to facilitate this workflow.
The workers actually
run on preemptable VMs.
So that's actually been
a huge mechanism for us
to control costs
in this process.
Preemptible VMs you
get at a fraction
of the cost of a
normal VM, but you
get that resource--
those compute resources
for a limited amount of time.
To engineer for
resilience to preemption,
we've done a couple of things.
One is checkpointing.
So we checkpoint
intermediate state out to GCS
as these workers run so that
if they do get preempted,
they can pick back up
from where they left off.
These jobs can be long running
on the order of minutes
at times just depending
on how much data there
is for a particular seed.
And with that in mind, with
that long running characteristic
in mind, we've implemented a job
lock using Cloud Memorystore.
So PubSub likes to
try to re deliver
these messages
sometimes before we're
ready to be done
with them, right?
So we've implemented them.
We've used Memorystore
as a simple job lock
where we write some metadata to
Memorystore as the job starts.
And then, if we get
reader delivered a message
from PubSub, we can
check and ensure
that we don't duplicate effort.
The last thing I
want to call out here
is that, again, this all comes
back to these resource APIs.
We're reading from
these resource APIs,
and writing output to
these resource APIs.
We're dog fooding all
of these resource APIs
that we're exposing
to our consumers.
We see the same surface they do.
So that forces us to
make sure that surface
is coherent and usable.
To give you a sense of how
much data we've generated,
again, 197 billion genotypes.
To backfill this,
the process itself is
meant to be always on, right?
As new data arrives,
we make new inferences.
We had to backfill
this in some way.
And we did that, again, by
dog fooding the process.
At a single moment in time--
actually, during Cloud Next
last year, we had a
Kubernetes cluster
that was using 42,500 virtual
CPUs all in preemptable nodes
at one time.
270 terabytes of memory.
And when we talk about
cost, we were doing this
at $0.01 per CPU
hour, which means
that as we scale
this process up,
our costs don't go
out of control, right?
This doesn't become prohibitive.
That's all I've got.
That's my Twitter handle.
We're always happy to talk about
what we do and how we do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]